good morning John we have recently
reached a number of milestones here on
the vogue of this channel we uploaded
our 1,500th vlogbrothers video we got
our three million subscriber and we're
about to upload our 100th episode of
dear Hank and John as soon as you get
back from vacation no rush I think this
is thus a good moment to take a look bad
and I'm gonna do that with the help of
the wayback machine this is a product
from the Internet Archive you can look
up any website you want to like go to
youtube.com and see what it looked like
back in the past
oh god it's beautiful I'll load it up
wait wait I'm a male seeking everyone
between eight with YouTube updating
saying this feels like information I
should have had in my head it's
beautiful but it's not what we're here
to look at today we're gonna take a look
at what youtube.com slash vlogbrothers
has looked like starting with today and
moving backwards in time YouTube has
looked pretty much the same for the last
like three years I don't super love it I
think we have to go pretty far back
before we see a significant change in
YouTube's design when our in 2014
same thing let's check out 2013 AHA this
is new I remember this this was the
design for quite a long time and I think
I remember being called by YouTube
cosmic Panda when it was first launched
it was a code name cosmic pan of the new
designers come and look at this
customization you could do you like all
of this is image map but if we continue
to go back back back in time we see that
we've broken the photo yeah I got a new
one oh yeah I remember that I like this
design around it you know you knew
exactly how it was gonna display but
it's sad that we can't have as much fun
as we once had let's pop it in 2010 year
back when we had first launched VidCon
oh yeah this is I liked this I also yeah
I remember doing that I don't know
what's happening all here with the
blankness but I've got three hundred
forty-four thousand subscribers we are
number 82 most subscribed all-time with
that number different now pushing the
truth or fail it never worked it was
such a good show that worked so hard
untrue there fail oh it was just never
it was destined to fail how maybe with
the new end screens it could work I
don't don't don't do it
alright let's go to 2009 alright yeah
this one this one that shark I Jones did
look at this is gorgeous
doesn't this look better than what it
looks like now one of the short sisters
Monica now works
for VidCon she's running pod con right
now August 2009 we have 98 thousand
subscribers so we're about to hit a
hundred thousand and look how nice all
this look I don't know how we ended up
with just John's face as our channel
icon alright we're gonna pop all the way
to 2008 now and probably lose this this
cooler design and end up with yeah this
Oh God
edit undo and then on the sidebar here
you got like comments on the channel I
think that we have like one channel
design left before we're out and here it
is is the first capture archive.org ever
made of vlogbrothers we had nine
thousand seven hundred subscribers
latest youtube drama subscribe to
householdhacker youtube watchdog has
twenty videos removed due to TOS
violation renato says the youtube
community is on its last breath because
of telemarketers there's been youtube
drama
since there has been youtube miss kate
chief says so since you have cracked
most subscribed guess you can just stop
making videos back in 2007 we thought
about it in december of 2007 absolutely
we said we were gonna do it for a year
we'd been doing it for a year we had
eleven thousand subscribers that was
super big back then it's not super big
now but yeah we decided to keep doing it
turned out okay our final archive.org
archive is from december 1st 2007 so
basically there's no record of our
YouTube channel for the first 11 months
that we did it John if you remember in
the early days YouTube was not where we
like had our main community we had it at
brotherhood to com if we go back to 2007
I think that we're gonna get oh yeah we
are oh yeah we are check it out
discussion questions how should Hank
take nerdfighters to the next level how
comes horseradish looks like Mayo and
tastes like poison
we don't do discussion questions anymore
that's fun how about this one what was
the first book you ever loved that's a
good one John thanks for doing stuff
with me afternoon recording for 36
minutes so there's probably a much
longer version of this video over on
Hanks channel John I'll see you on
Tuesday